também não é e porque não a gente nem
qualquer um
não isso aqui não é o meu quarto tá isso
não não é o meu quarto não queria muito
que fosse queria que fosse mesmo é o
seguinte modo o brasil fazer show em
casar novamente lugar que eu faço três
quatro cinco sessões 11 sessões com
funks brasil obrigado brasil e volta e
meia os caba sentido dó de mim faz não
vou bater num quarto legal é montado
neste aqui que tem essa banheira não é
um motel também está mas é massa já em 3
já tirei foto é manter puro da família
e aí galera que assistiu ao canal tudo
com você e eu muito bem santo melhor que
o do gripado eu odeio ficar doente odeia
então por que tanto ódio é de ficar
doente primeiro quem fica mal causa do
gol o segundo caso das perguntas que a
pessoa que vê a pessoa doente e não
consegue ficar calado observar que
absoluta de que ela tem que ficar
perguntando lixo está gripado não por
tudo de bom e se quieto espirrando agora
a gripe e vinho já espirrei dos preciso
mais pesado aquelas torcida gasto se que
o catar país que quebrou a parede do
peito que o estúdio que da ump pouco no
peito que dá vontade está presa no novo
gente a ser tóxico catarro vencer
encosta o catar no chão ea pressão da
pergunta e isso é catar metalvales é não
político nem saber que minha boca fala
da [__] matar muito pink remédio que já
vou ficar bom já que amanhã é a páscoa
a faca o que é a páscoa a páscoa o
momento que a gente come ovos de
chocolate kan eo google wave vai deixar
parental ou não é isso acho engraçado
que a criança desde pequena aprendi que
o coelho vem trazer os ovos de páscoa
para para para para e pensa onde é no
mundo que coelho botão o pequeno botão
quando foi parar na fazenda tatu vai ser
meu deus aquele coelho se contassem nada
tá com dor de barriga
alguém ajuda das varela judeci coelho o
que é isso que está a acontecer
olha é um ovo não é mais fácil a galinha
cada um coelho do tempo em total valec
no google está no google é verdade a cor
cada dia estão a passeio começa na sexta
feira santa onde é celebrada a
crucificação de jesus cristo é no
domingo de páscoa que celebra sua
ressurreição e o aparecimento aos seus
discípulos jesus já que a páscoa celebra
a ressurreição de jesus meu deus
nestlé-garoto bota - resumiu nuno coddou
da páscoa ver se a pessoa lembra de
jesus no dia pego o ovo de páscoa o bota
luís pato pessoal olha aqui o coelho vai
fazer você bota 50 mil dólar em baixa de
jesus a insurreição para as pessoas
entender o que é o povo esquece jesus na
passagem única pessoa que lembra de
jesus na pasta é o vovô da gente não
pode comer carne na pasta não pode comer
cá a semana santa na semana santa não
pode comer carne só porque o que é
pecado a lua oi querido tudo bem pra
comprar coisas pra gente fazer que
acordo de paz que em casa só não
completar de porque é pecado tá não
compra menino diabo à solta nas axilas e
até rock ruim eu podia ter matado ofício
perto do fogo do teu pai amor não compra
carne porque é pecado comercais semana
santa não com precisa só de falar uma
coisa que tu viu os gols saber da
claudinha aqui é que fez os vídeos
pornográficos fez passou a tisatto amor
que vagabunda não manteiga onde foi sem
querer namorada o que faz coisa
vagabunda tem que ir pro inferno morri
mesmo tá só não comprei carro e é pecado
come carne tamo comprar cachaça muita
cachaça bancos liberdade pois vamos
dirigir atropela pessoas bairros carne
não
compra carne que é amor peta pelo amor
de deus vem lá pra casa museu toda toda
não importa que a gente não é casado
isso não tem nada a ver o que vamos
fazer todas as publicações sim dessa
cama vovô vou fazer tudo ser pesquisado
sem imaginar todos o domingo morreu vai
pena não comprei canino a boca não amor
pelo amor de deus é pecado amor favor
não pô menino já falei cá eu vou pegar
show de páscoa foi fiador de tempo mas
aprendi a me respeitar e não complicar
no amor e pecado como enchente assim de
mata do paço antônio fazendo merda na
semana santa não vou comer carne porque
é pecado eo resto não é não poder ser
botar o ano santo na sua vida você faz
coisas boas todo o passo que sobre quem
chen no saco e chocolate quente tinha se
até os chocolates pra mim eu sei que eu
sou bem gordinho que quer porque quer
coisa o chocolate entanto sabe como é
que a gente diz país não comer chocolate
sobre gordinha que diga que subi na
bochecha que não tem pescoço e fica de
molho de chocolate altar dizer o meu
filho luca de chocolate da fitness
academia hora dessa hipótese agora
chocolate pra você mas eu trouxe aqui
toma um ovo de alface e sobre rico que
conhece a moça ganhou chocolate chega na
casa da pessoa me a ver com o puxando ou
de 30 quilos só pensando meu deus
dinheiro que esse mini cooper seu de
passar de pagamentos contrário e luiz
tanta coisa em casa na internet contou
só que eu sou daquele jeito que ela tem
condição de comprar compra não tem
condição no corpo fica calado em casa o
pessoal vai ficar com o pai não é porque
o ovo de páscoa de 400 gramas ele curso
e que 50 reais e uma barra de chocolate
400 gramas gente custa r$10 do bc que
comprou de taiko só porque o mesmo peso
e é mais barata engraçado é que um fiat
uno pesa 800 quilos e é 25 mil reais eu
tenho uma tia minha que parece o fit
honda placa na cabeça dela estava no
chão pensando em um táxi é de graça ela
quer que quer é rebaixada tchecas perda
de curtir por quem é quem
quero copra a melhor coisa que tem é
semanas até escapar do dólar surra ou
coisa boa que se lança não pode bater em
mim também é pecado eu faço uma nação
desgraça vem aqui tomar foi a voz ea
mancha bater moisés e receber sua irmã
quatro e meia atual rito tirou 4 que vai
levar à pisa costa mãe de refeição de
jesus mas até agora de manhã tap um
simples crianças ganhou nelba de
chocolate equivalente a um ovo de
chocolate porque é mais barato era muito
quente acostumado e se esquecido detalhe
a semana santa o livro-agenda a sua mais
um dia ela acaba meu deus anac o estudo
quebrou meu prato em agosto vai levar
semana antes do domingo de páscoa foi
ontem hoje não é mais semana santa não é
não
a semana do inferno que a senhora tá com
cara de demônio
se você vai gostar desse vídeo já sabe o
que fazer aqui no youtube que nesse
botão gente aqui em baixo assim eu
gostei muita gente a assistir o vídeo a
cabo e sai e esquece de clicarem gostei
mas não esqueça no click agora nesse
momento gostei aqui em baixo o dólar no
facebook eu postei civil no meu facebook
um vídeo novo não revela se clique em
curtir lá e marca seus amigos perceber
como era da semana santa o momento aqui
embaixo que você mais gosta da semana
santa no canal pra toda vez tiver um
vídeo novo vai receber aí valeu é nóis
painel e de hepatite
é essa luz na minha lojinha a descrição
do vídeo nós